let's speak to some people
in the audience right i mean i think
that that makes absolute and perfect
sense uh you can join the discussion on
our discord at davidpakman.com
discord we use the waiting lobby
to indicate that you would like to speak
to me and of course do not send me any
direct messages we have a system get in
the waiting lobby if you send me direct
messages saying david david please put
me on unfortunately i have to mute you
and i will never hear from you again
that's the way it works
let's go
first
to our friend jen in providence jen
great to have you back on
uh hi can you hear me i can hear you
fine
all right great um so you know living in
a liberal area like new england a lot of
people have that peace of mind thinking
oh as far as the abortion rights they're
never gonna come for us we're gonna be
safe up here
but do you think it really is only a
matter of time until they just really
try to make it federal and try to creep
up i mean rhode island is even almost
purple it's not solid blue like
massachusetts is right do you think
we're in any danger in the future
i think it would be a bad idea to assume
that they're never coming for abortion
with a federal abortion ban in fact
there's already people talking about it
there's already people saying hey listen
if we can get rid of roe v wade maybe a
total ban would actually be a
possibility so i think to your point jen
it would be at one's own peril to put
our guard down and to say well as long
as we just lobby for it to remain legal
within the states in which we live we
don't have to worry about it that seems
extremely dangerous and naive to me now
i'm not saying
they will get a federal abortion ban
necessarily anytime soon but they we
don't have to wonder whether they're
thinking about it they're telling us
that they're thinking about it
yeah and what's interesting about the
design of providence too we get to see
the effects of if they did go through
with this ban on one street there is a
planned parenthood a homeless shelter
and department of human services so it's
kind of showing that triad of what
happens if these women are meant to have
kids that they can't afford yeah
um but none of these people who are
screaming pro-life are going to you know
the homeless shelter and donating and
they're the same ones they get mad when
they have to go by like the food stamp
in the welfare office absolutely it is
incredible and as i've said before a lot
of the very same people who want to make
it impossible or illegal to get an
abortion are unwilling to say well we
should expand and codify the child tax
credit at a higher level we should
provide uh contraceptions uh
comprehensive sex education all these
different things not only are they
hypocrites but they're dangerous
hypocrites
exactly all right well i thank you so
much i'll let you get to everybody else
all right jen from providence look did
you see how other than that one audio
glitch she gets right to the question
she knows other people are waiting what
what a great call really a fantastic
phone call it is a brand new year maybe
you have goals around getting in better
shape maybe cutting back on sugar that's
why you should check out our long time
sponsor magic spoon magic spoon tastes
exactly like the delicious sweet
breakfast cereals you loved as a kid but
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar 14
grams of protein and only four net carbs
so it's perfect if you're doing low carb
or keto or if like me you just try to
limit your sugar intake you can build
your own variety pack with flavors like
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
cinnamon cookies and cream waffle maple
blueberry that's my favorite magic spoon
lets you enjoy a sweet delicious snack
without the guilt you can stick to your
goals and still treat yourself and if
you don't love magic spoon as much as i
do they'll give you all of your money
back no questions asked magic spoon is
giving my audience five dollars off when
you go to magicspoon.com
pacman and use the promo code pacman